This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's a big, old apartment building in South Minneapolis that looks out of place. It's in a residential neighborhood with small bungalows and some auto body shops. But this apartment building fills up an entire corner lot.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在南明尼阿波利斯有一栋又大又旧的公寓楼，看起来与周围格格不入。它坐落在一个住宅区，周围是小小的平房和一些汽车修理厂。但这栋公寓楼却占据了整个街角地块。
I've bypassed this place hundreds of times, and it always struck me as kind of weird. That's reporter Katie Thornton. I started digging through old newspapers and I found out why it's there. That building is the last remnant of an early 1900s amusement park. It was called Wonderland. A friend of a friend named Hillary lives there now
我经过这里几百次了，它总让我觉得有点奇怪。那是记者凯蒂·桑顿。我开始翻阅旧报纸，终于发现了它存在的原因。那栋建筑是20世纪初一个游乐园的最后遗迹。它叫“仙境”。一个朋友的朋友希拉里现在住在那儿，
and she gave me a tour. We are at my apartment building. It's on the corner of 31st and 31st since South Minneapolis. As I understand it, there was an amusement park here. The park had a roller coaster and a dance hall and a log flume, but the biggest attraction was something much stranger. A bizarre side show that used to fill the apartment complex where Hillary lives now. When she signed the lease, her landlord told her the building used to be called the Infantorium.
她带我参观了一下。我们现在就在我的公寓楼里。它位于南明尼阿波利斯的第31街和第31街的拐角处。据我所知，这里曾经有一个游乐园。公园里有过山车、舞厅和急流勇进，但最大的景点是某种更奇怪的东西。一个离奇的杂耍表演，曾经就填满了希拉里现在居住的这栋公寓楼。当她签租约时，房东告诉她，这栋楼过去叫“婴儿馆”。
What he said at the time was like they had premature babies living in this building and being taken care of in the building as part of the attraction of the park. Visitors to the Infantorium would pay 10 cents to enter a spacious room full of glass boxes. They were incubators with tiny premature babies on display. And this wasn't the only place this was happening. The fact that there was a pavilion for incubator babies at Wonderland is not an isolated incident.
他当时说，就像是他们把早产儿养在这栋楼里，作为公园景点的一部分来照顾。参观“婴儿馆”的游客会花10美分进入一个宽敞的房间，里面摆满了玻璃箱。那是些保育箱，里面展示着小小的早产儿。而且这并不是唯一发生这种情况的地方。在“仙境”游乐园里有一个保育箱婴儿展馆，这并非孤立事件。
Lauren McBenefits is an amusement park historian. Incubators for premature babies were oddly enough a phenomenon at the turn of the century that was available at state and county fairs and amusement parks rather than hospitals. At this moment in history, if you wanted your at-risk premature baby to survive, you pretty much had to bring them to an amusement park. These incubator shows cropped up across America. They were the main source of healthcare for premature babies for over 40 years. for premature babies for over 40 years.
劳伦·麦克贝内菲茨是一位游乐园历史学家。奇怪的是，早产儿保育箱在世纪之交是一种现象，它更多出现在州博览会、县博览会和游乐园，而不是医院。在那个历史时刻，如果你想让你处于危险中的早产儿存活下来，你几乎必须把他们带到游乐园去。这些保育箱展览在美国各地涌现。在超过40年的时间里，它们是早产儿医疗保健的主要来源。
When the incubator attraction started in the late 1800s, the world was a lot deadlier. Almost one in five babies in the United States died before childhood, and that was an improvement from the previous decades. At the turn of the century, 19 of 20 births were still happening at home, which isn't a problem if your baby is healthy, but not all of them were. Like today, a lot of babies were born too early. The majority of American hospitals had nothing to help them. No technology, no special skills.
当保育箱景点在19世纪末开始出现时，世界要致命得多。在美国，几乎每五个婴儿中就有一个在童年之前夭折，这与过去几十年相比已经是一种进步了。在世纪之交，20个新生儿中仍有19个是在家里出生的，如果你的宝宝很健康，这没问题，但并非所有宝宝都如此。和今天一样，很多婴儿出生得太早。大多数美国医院没有任何东西可以帮助他们。没有技术，也没有特殊技能。
There was no central heating to keep them warm. Doctors would place heated bricks in cribs and cross their fingers. In private, people tried everything to keep premature babies alive. They put these infants and boxes stuffed with feathers to keep them warm. They rubbed oil on the babies and kept them near fireplaces. But more than three-quarters of premature babies were dying. In America, no one in the medical community was trying to solve this problem. But things look different over in France.
当时没有中央供暖来保持他们的体温。医生们会把加热过的砖块放在婴儿床里，然后祈祷好运。在私下里，人们尝试各种方法来让早产儿活下来。他们把这些婴儿放在塞满羽毛的盒子里来保暖。他们给婴儿涂油，并把他们放在壁炉旁。但超过四分之三的早产儿还是夭折了。在美国，医疗界没有人试图解决这个问题。但在法国，情况看起来不同。
French doctors stole an idea from the poultry industry, which used incubators to hatch chicken eggs. They designed a human version. Basically, it was a warm box heated by a hot water tank below. In the 1890s, a Frenchman named Alexander Lyon modernized the whole thing. The air in Lyon's incubator was heated by a pipe flowing with hot water. The temperature was pretty consistent, and the box was ventilated. But Lyon's real innovation was to put a big glass window on the box.
法国医生从家禽业偷学了一个点子，家禽业使用孵化器来孵化鸡蛋。他们设计了一个人类版本。基本上，它就是一个由下方热水箱加热的暖箱。在19世纪90年代，一个叫亚历山大·里昂的法国人将整个装置现代化了。里昂保育箱里的空气是由流着热水的管道加热的。温度相当稳定，而且箱子有通风装置。但里昂真正的创新是在箱子上装了一个大玻璃窗。
And then, he filled the box with a baby. He built a better machine, and he displayed it at the Berlin Industrial Exposition in 1896. Don Raffel is the author of the new book about the unexpected origins of modern incubation. He showed the new machine with preemies inside and it was a sensation. There were drinking hall songs about it. He called it Dijkinder Brutenstall which was literally child hatchery and so it took on the environment of a side show. Some carnival showmen bought knockoff machines
然后，他把一个婴儿放进了箱子里。他制造了一台更好的机器，并在1896年的柏林工业博览会上展示了它。唐·拉斐尔是关于现代保育箱意外起源的新书作者。他展示了里面装着早产儿的新机器，这引起了轰动。当时甚至有关于它的酒馆歌曲。他称之为“Dijkinder Brutenstall”，字面意思是“儿童孵化场”，于是它带上了杂耍表演的氛围。一些嘉年华表演者买了仿制机器，
and started charging entry to their own premature baby shows. But keeping a baby alive is more complicated than putting them in a box and flipping a switch. So most of them got out of the business pretty quickly. But one showman was hooked on this idea. In 1897, Dr. Martin Cooney put on his first incubator baby show in London. Somehow he may have just gotten down to the idea of this is a kind of a cool way to make money in the beginning.
并开始对他们自己的早产儿展览收费。但让婴儿活下来比把他们放进盒子里并按下开关要复杂得多。所以他们大多数人很快就退出了这个行业。但有一位表演者迷上了这个点子。1897年，马丁·库尼医生在伦敦举办了他的第一场保育箱婴儿展。不知何故，他可能只是想到了这是一种赚钱的好方法。
So he went with this show. Unlike other showmen, Cooney hired nurses to hold the babies and feed them breast milk. The babies were healthier and survived at higher rates. The public loved it. So Dr. Cuny decided to try it out in the United States, at the Omaha World's Fair. Details were always a little vague when Cuny told his life story to Americans, but a few points stayed consistent. He was from Europe, and he was trained in Germany and France,
所以他坚持做了这个展览。与其他表演者不同，库尼雇佣了护士来抱婴儿并喂他们母乳。婴儿们更健康，存活率也更高。公众很喜欢它。于是库尼医生决定在美国的奥马哈世界博览会上尝试一下。当库尼向美国人讲述他的人生故事时，细节总是有点模糊，但有几点是一致的。他来自欧洲，在德国和法国受过培训，
which were decades ahead of the US in terms of medical education. He called himself Dr. Martin Kune, though his given name was actually Michael Kohn. And he said he'd just arrived in the US for the first time, though he'd actually immigrated from Poland about a decade earlier. Like a good showman, he had a knack for exaggeration. Sometimes he said he invented the incubators he didn't.
这两个国家在医学教育方面领先美国几十年。他自称马丁·库尼医生，尽管他的本名其实是迈克尔·科恩。他说他刚第一次来到美国，尽管他其实大约十年前就从波兰移民过来了。像个优秀的表演者一样，他有夸大的天赋。有时他说他发明了保育箱，其实他并没有。
Dr. Cuny beckoned people to his show with bold, hand-painted signs that said things like wonderful invention and infant incubators with living infants. Lots of spectators came and so did parents of premature babies who handed them over to Dr. Cooney, hoping for a miracle. Cooney perfected his side show at the 1901 World's Fair in Buffalo, New York. That fair has gone down in infamy as the place where President Wayne McKenley was shot and later died of gangrene.
库尼医生用大胆的手绘招牌吸引人们来看他的展览，上面写着“奇妙的发明”和“带有活体婴儿的婴儿保育箱”之类的话。很多观众来了，早产儿的父母也来了，他们把孩子交给库尼医生，希望能有奇迹发生。库尼在1901年纽约布法罗的世界博览会上完善了他的杂耍表演。那届博览会因威廉·麦金莱总统在那里被枪击并最终死于坏疽而臭名昭著。
But aside from that, people had a really good time at the fair. Dr. Cooney was set up on the midway. It's the section filled with carnival rides and side shows. And then Buffalo, it was popping off with attractions like House Upside Down and Jerusalem on the morning of the crucifixion. Thousands of people paid 10 cents each to see Dr. Cuny's incubator show.
但除此之外，人们在博览会上玩得很开心。库尼医生在游乐场中段安营扎寨。那是充满嘉年华游乐设施和杂耍表演的区域。在布法罗，那里有“颠倒屋”和“受难日的耶路撒冷”等景点，非常火爆。成千上万的人每人花10美分去看库尼医生的保育箱展览。
They had barkers outside saying, don't forget to see the babies. Maybe the future president is inside. He knew how to be a showman. He knew how to talk to people, and he loved talking to people. Dr. Cuny greeted thousands of people on the midway. His exhibit was full of futuristic glass incubators. One reporter wrote in Cosmopolitan that Kuni's incubator babies were more exciting than Niagara Falls.
他们在外面有招揽客人的吆喝者说：“别忘了看婴儿。也许未来的总统就在里面。”他知道如何成为一名表演者。他知道如何与人交谈，而且他热爱与人交谈。库尼医生在游乐场中段迎接了成千上万的人。他的展位里摆满了未来主义的玻璃保育箱。一位记者在《大都会》杂志上写道，库尼的保育箱婴儿比尼亚加拉大瀑布更令人兴奋。
Newspapers as far away as Hawaii reported on the survival of the infants. It was like a reality TV show in some ways where there were people who would come every week to look at the babies and they'd have a favorite that they'd be rooting for. A local medical journal reported that 48 of the 52 babies delivered to Cuny that summer had survived.
远至夏威夷的报纸都报道了这些婴儿的存活情况。在某种程度上，这就像一个真人秀节目，有些人每周都会来看这些婴儿，他们会有自己支持的“心头好”。当地一份医学杂志报道称，那个夏天送到库尼那里的52个婴儿中有48个存活了下来。
But even so, American doctors were not banging down Cuny's door for his machines. This life-saving technology was stuck on the midway. Despite the big crowds and the good press, Cuny was still spending more money than he was bringing in. midway. basically had to build a NICU. And then when the whole thing is over, you have to tear it all down. Luckily for CUNY, a new fad was sweeping the country in the early 1900s. Amusement parks took all the excitement of the fair midways and made them permanent.
但即便如此，美国医生并没有为了他的机器而踏破库尼的门槛。这项救命的技术被困在了游乐场中段。尽管观众众多，媒体评价也不错，但库尼的支出仍然超过了收入。基本上必须建造一个新生儿重症监护室。然后当一切结束时，你必须把它全部拆掉。幸运的是，20世纪初，一种新风尚席卷了全国。游乐园把博览会中段的所有兴奋点都变成了永久性的。
In the early 1900s, amusement parks were popping up all over the country, like all over the country. In 1909, a reporter from Pittsburgh apologized on behalf of the city. He wrote, we regret that we are possibly the only city in the country of any consequence that will go through the coming summer season with only three amusement parks. By 1910, every US city with at least 20,000 people had their own park.
在20世纪初，游乐园在全国各地如雨后春笋般涌现。1909年，一位来自匹兹堡的记者代表该市道歉。他写道：“我们很遗憾，我们可能是全国唯一一个在即将到来的夏季只有三个游乐园的重要城市。”到1910年，每个拥有至少2万人口的美国城市都有了自己的公园。
People wanted to have fun, and amusement parks were all about unbridled pleasure. It's not an intellectual thing at all, it's just a kind of giddy physical amusement. The attendance figures for these parks are phenomenal. You could get things like a quarter of the population of a medium-sized city on a weekend. Most of the early parks were owned by electric trolley companies who use the parks to get passengers on their trains.
人们想要娱乐，而游乐园就是关于肆无忌惮的快乐。这根本不是什么理性的东西，只是一种令人眩晕的身体娱乐。这些公园的入场人数非常惊人。周末时，你甚至能吸引到一个中等城市四分之一的人口。大多数早期的公园都由电力电车公司拥有，他们利用公园来吸引乘客乘坐他们的火车。
The trolley lines would also end at the amusement park and the electric cables from the train would be hooked up to power the rollercoasters. The parks were places where new technology was smuggled into American society under the guise of entertainment. At the time, there was a lot of uneasiness about new technology. Electric trains, lights, and motors weren't always safe, but in amusement parks, technology
电车线路也会在游乐园终点站，火车的电缆会被连接起来为过山车供电。这些公园是新技术以娱乐为幌子被引入美国社会的地方。当时，人们对新技术有很多不安。电动火车、灯光和电机并不总是安全的，但在游乐园里，技术
wasn't something to be feared or mistrusted. Playing with these things, making them part of leisure and recreation, acclimated people to them physically with their bodies, but also made them pleasurable, made them pleasurable at a time when there might be some anxiety about these new technologies. When people got on thrill rides or watched firework displays, they saw that technology could be fun and safe. In a way, Dr. Kuni's incubator babies were the essence of amusement parks.
并不是什么值得恐惧或怀疑的东西。玩这些东西，把它们作为休闲和娱乐的一部分，不仅在身体上让人们适应了它们，而且在人们对这些新技术可能感到焦虑的时候，让它们变得令人愉悦。当人们乘坐惊险游乐设施或观看烟花表演时，他们看到技术可以是既有趣又安全的。在某种程度上，库尼医生的保育箱婴儿就是游乐园的精髓。
And Kuni's exhibit in Buffalo caught the eye of two businessmen who were planning to build a brand new park in Kony Island. They saw this is a really cool show. It's as interesting as a ride. This would work at an amusement park. Kony Island already had two other self-contained amusement parks, and until it burned down in 1896, a seven-story hotel shaped like an elephant. But these businessmen were taking it to the next level.
库尼在布法罗的展览引起了两位计划在康尼岛建造一个全新公园的商人的注意。他们认为这是一个非常酷的表演。它和游乐设施一样有趣。这在游乐园里会很受欢迎。康尼岛已经有两个独立的游乐园，在1896年烧毁之前，还有一个七层楼高的大象形状的酒店。但这些商人要把事情提升到一个新的水平。
Their new endeavor would be called Luna Park. It featured a ride imported from Buffalo, called a trip to the moon. It brought passengers into a paper-machae fantasy world full of scientifically incorrect foliage and 200 actors playing moon people. And among Luna Park's flagship attractions was Dr. Kuni's incubator babies. When the sun set on May 16th, 1903, Luna Park switched on 250,000 electric light bulbs and opened their gates to 60,000 people who gathered outside. Many of them made a beeline for the babies. Coney Island was the start of something big for Dr. Coney. In the spring of 1905, he traveled to Chicago, Denver, and Minneapolis to set up new exhibits.
他们的新事业被称为“月神公园”。它以从布法罗引进的名为“月球之旅”的游乐设施为特色。它把乘客带入一个充满科学上不正确的植物和200名扮演月球人的演员的纸糊幻想世界。月神公园的旗舰景点之一就是库尼医生的保育箱婴儿。1903年5月16日太阳落山时，月神公园点亮了25万个电灯泡，向聚集在外面的6万人敞开了大门。他们中的许多人直奔婴儿展区。康尼岛是库尼医生事业的一个重大开端。1905年春天，他前往芝加哥、丹佛和明尼阿波利斯设立了新的展览。
His incubators captivated audiences across the country and he became stinking rich. Kuni bought a nice house near the shore on Kuni Island where he was known to host extravagant dinners. If Dr. Kuni was in it for the money, he got what he wanted. But the thing is, he made a lot of choices that weren't driven by profit. He really wanted to save babies and to get the incubators into hospitals. In his travels, Kuni would whine and dine doctors and give them demonstrations of the incubators.
他的保育箱吸引了全国各地的观众，他变得非常有钱。库尼在康尼岛岸边买了一栋漂亮的房子，他以举办奢华的晚宴而闻名。如果库尼医生是为了钱，他得到了他想要的。但问题是，他做了很多并非出于利润驱动的选择。他真心想拯救婴儿，并把保育箱引入医院。在旅行中，库尼会宴请医生，并向他们演示保育箱。
On multiple occasions, he tried to get health departments to use his incubators after the local fair season was over. He even tried to donate his incubators to the city of San Francisco, but no one would take them. Doctors had all sorts of reasons for rejecting the technology. One reason was the disgraceful influence of the eugenics movement. In 1901, an anonymous editorial made the rounds in medical journals asking if the incubators should be shut down. The author wrote that the human race suffered by keeping alive babies
在多次场合，他试图在当地博览会季节结束后让卫生部门使用他的保育箱。他甚至试图把他的保育箱捐给旧金山市，但没有人愿意接受。医生们拒绝这项技术有各种各样的理由。其中一个原因是优生学运动的恶劣影响。1901年，一篇匿名社论在医学期刊上流传，询问是否应该关闭这些保育箱。作者写道，人类种族因维持那些
who would, quote, transmit their deficiencies, deformities, and vices to the next generation. Eugenics was a hateful and racist pseudoscience, and it was not a fringe movement. A lot of the fairs where Cuny showed his babies also had eugenics exhibits. There were lots of other concerns about Cuny's approach, like maybe amusement parks weren't the best place for fragile infants. I think of them primarily as an assault on your senses, the noise, the bright lights, the smells of food. They were somewhat seedy. Amusement parks were noisy, and a lot of them served alcohol and had gambling. And they became known as places where young people of all different backgrounds bumped a little more than Alboes. You could make out in the tunnel of love or flirt on
会“将缺陷、畸形和恶习遗传给下一代”的婴儿的生命而受损。优生学是一种可恶的种族主义伪科学，它并非边缘运动。库尼展示婴儿的许多博览会也有优生学展览。关于库尼的方法还有很多其他担忧，比如游乐园可能不是脆弱婴儿的最佳场所。我认为它们主要是对感官的冲击，噪音、明亮的灯光、食物的气味。它们有点破败。游乐园很吵，而且很多地方供应酒精并有赌博活动。它们被称为各种背景的年轻人碰撞得比肘部更亲密的地方。你可以在“爱之隧道”里亲热，或者在
the dance floor and then you would head over to the babies. This juxtaposition made some people uneasy. In the midways could be incredibly dangerous. Many of the parks were built quickly, were pretty shoddy and prone to fire. One time in 1911, a Kony Island park with one of Kooni's incubator shows went up in flames. A New York Times stop the press and reported on the front page that all the babies had died. That was actually not true. It was an error. All the babies had in fact survived. And beyond the safety concerns, there was something deeply unsettling about the incubator shows. Today, it's clear that putting babies on display and profiting off them is unquestionably
舞池里调情，然后你就会走向婴儿展区。这种并置让一些人感到不安。游乐场中段可能非常危险。许多公园建造得很快，相当粗制滥造，容易发生火灾。1911年，康尼岛一个有库尼保育箱展览的公园着火了。《纽约时报》停刊并头版报道称所有婴儿都死了。那其实不是真的。那是一个错误。事实上，所有婴儿都幸存了下来。除了安全问题，保育箱展览还有一些令人深感不安的地方。今天，很明显，把婴儿当作展品并从中获利无疑是
exploitative. In many ways, Kunis exhibits were in line with the worst parts of amusement parks and world's fares. In addition to the rides, many fares and parks had ethnological villages, where Native Americans or people from faraway nations would live on site in stereotyped caricatures of their homes. Some people were literally caged and incarcerated on the grounds, with no record of payment. On a lot of midways, there was a despicable willingness to exploit human life, for the entertainment of the privileged.
剥削性的。在许多方面，库尼的展览与游乐园和世界博览会最糟糕的部分是一致的。除了游乐设施，许多博览会和公园还有“民族村”，美洲原住民或来自遥远国家的人们会住在现场，展示他们家园的刻板印象。有些人甚至被关在场地里，没有报酬记录。在许多游乐场中段，有一种为了特权阶层的娱乐而剥削人类生命的卑劣意愿。
And charging money to see struggling infants was another manifestation of this unethical practice. And while we're talking about our discomfort with incubator shows, there's one more thing that should make you uncomfortable with Dr. Cooney. He wasn't a real doctor. There is no medical license on record for him in this country. In the cities where he said he attended medical school and Germany, there is no record of his matriculation
而收费观看挣扎中的婴儿是这种不道德行为的另一种表现。当我们谈论对保育箱展览的不适感时，还有一件事应该让你对库尼医生感到不舒服。他不是真正的医生。在这个国家，没有他的医疗执照记录。在他声称就读过医学院的德国城市，也没有他入学
in any of those schools. This was not common knowledge. Even Kuni's obituary said he was a doctor. Kuni always told his staff that he had a license to practice in Europe, but it just hadn't transferred to the US or something like that. They followed his instructions, the babies lived, and he worked magic with the media and passers-by.
任何这些学校的记录。这不是常识。甚至库尼的讣告也说他是医生。库尼总是告诉他的员工，他在欧洲有执业执照，只是没有转到美国之类的。他们听从了他的指示，婴儿们活了下来，他用媒体和路人施展了魔法。
So Dr. Cuny was a fraud, but that doesn't mean his contribution to medicine wasn't real. The babies in his care were more than four times as likely to survive and to childhood. Saving the babies became Martin Cunney's mission. He liked to say he was making propaganda for primis. His staff took care in nurturing the babies, even feeding those two week to suckle through the nose with a dropper. He took babies of all races and classes, and he never once charged the families. Everything was funded by admissions.
所以库尼医生是个骗子，但这并不意味着他对医学的贡献不是真实的。在他照顾下的婴儿存活到童年的可能性是其他婴儿的四倍多。拯救婴儿成了马丁·库尼的使命。他喜欢说他是在为早产儿做宣传。他的员工细心呵护这些婴儿，甚至用滴管通过鼻子喂养那些太虚弱而无法吮吸的婴儿。他接收各种种族和阶级的婴儿，而且从未向家庭收取过费用。一切都由门票收入资助。
After 35 years of CunY's incubator exhibits, his side show was still the best place to keep a premature baby alive. By the 1930s, most hospitals hadn't created alternatives to the infantarium, so people kept bringing their newborns to the midway. But in the depths of the Great Depression, incubators finally made a breakthrough when Martin Cooney teamed up with a sympathetic doctor in Chicago.
在库尼的保育箱展览进行了35年后，他的杂耍表演仍然是让早产儿活下来的最佳场所。到20世纪30年代，大多数医院还没有创造出替代“婴儿馆”的方法，所以人们继续把新生儿带到游乐场中段。但在大萧条时期，当马丁·库尼与芝加哥的一位富有同情心的医生合作时，保育箱终于取得了突破。
That's where he met Dr. Julius Hass, who was everything Martin Cooney wasn't. He was a real doctor. He had absolutely stellar credentials. And Hass was very impressed with what Martin Coney was doing and Hess really learned a lot of what he knew from Dr. Cunney. Hess was a respected physician with a passion for infant care, and over the years, he saw how Cunney's system was saving a lot of people. But Hess had to be careful with his associations, like Cunney, he was also up against the medical
他在那里遇到了朱利叶斯·赫斯医生，他拥有马丁·库尼所没有的一切。他是一位真正的医生。他拥有绝对一流的资历。赫斯对马丁·库尼所做的事情印象深刻，赫斯确实从库尼医生那里学到了很多他所知道的东西。赫斯是一位受人尊敬的医生，对婴儿护理充满热情，多年来，他看到了库尼的系统是如何拯救了许多人的。但赫斯必须小心他的交往，像库尼一样，他也面临着医疗
system that didn't seem to care if these babies lived or died. Hes wanted his cause to be taken seriously. And being the doctor that endorsed the medical side show at the local amusement park, wasn't a good look. Hes designed his own incubator, and in the 1920s, he got a little bit of funding to open an infant wing at his Chicago hospital. But it couldn't keep up with demand.
系统，那个系统似乎并不在乎这些婴儿是死是活。赫斯希望他的事业被认真对待。而作为支持当地游乐园医疗杂耍表演的医生，这看起来并不好。赫斯设计了自己的保育箱，并在20世纪20年代获得了一些资金，在他的芝加哥医院开设了一个婴儿病房。但它无法满足需求。
Julius has been struggling within the system to try to get publicity and funding and just couldn't get enough. He was turning away patients because he didn't have the resources. He needed a publicity machine. And Martin Cooney at that point needed respectability. When Chicago hosted the World's Fair in 1933, Cooney's exhibit had the explicit support Martin Cuny at that point needed respectability. When Chicago hosted the World's Fair in 1933, Cuny's exhibit had the explicit support of Julius Hess, and that carried a lot of weight.
朱利叶斯一直在系统内挣扎，试图获得宣传和资金，但就是无法获得足够的支持。他因为没有资源而不得不拒绝病人。他需要一台宣传机器。而马丁·库尼当时需要体面。当芝加哥在1933年举办世界博览会时，库尼的展览得到了朱利叶斯·赫斯的明确支持，这分量很重。
Even Chicago's health commissioner got on board. The fair ran for two summers, and in the second summer, they held an incubator baby reunion event. Joyous mothers carried their one-year-old babies and shrolled down the midway. Each baby had been saved by the incubators just one year before. After the fair, Chicago became the first city in America to create a public health policy specifically for premature infants. Dr. Julius Hess became known as the father of American neonatology.
甚至芝加哥的卫生专员也加入了进来。博览会举办了两个夏天，在第二个夏天，他们举办了一场保育箱婴儿重聚活动。快乐的母亲们抱着她们一岁大的婴儿在游乐场中段漫步。每个婴儿都是在一年前被保育箱救下的。博览会结束后，芝加哥成为美国第一个为早产儿制定公共卫生政策的城市。朱利叶斯·赫斯医生被称为“美国新生儿学之父”。
And with the blessing of the Chicago medical community, other cities started putting incubators in their hospitals too. As doctors gone on board, Kunis and Fantorium started shutting down across the country. By the 1940s, Kunis Island was the last of his exhibitions
在芝加哥医学界的祝福下，其他城市也开始在医院里安装保育箱。随着医生们的加入，库尼的“婴儿馆”开始在全国范围内关闭。到20世纪40年代，康尼岛是他最后一个展览
taking babies. And some of those babies are still alive today. I've had people refer to what it does the Kunis hospital and all all this kind of terminology, but it was no such thing. It was a side show. This is Beth Allen, born in Brooklyn in 1941. Yes, well, I was one of the last group of babies that he took care of.
接收婴儿的地方。其中一些婴儿今天仍然活着。我听过人们把库尼所做的事情称为“库尼医院”之类的术语，但根本没有那回事。那是一个杂耍表演。这是贝丝·艾伦，1941年出生在布鲁克林。是的，我是他照顾的最后一批婴儿之一。
He was not a young man then. 78 years ago, Beth's mother was rushed to a hospital near her house. She had been pregnant just six months. She pushed out two painfully tiny twins. One died shortly after childbirth. Beth was a mere shadow of an infant. At just over a pound and a half, she weighed less than a third of what she should have weighed. The hospital staff had no choice but to tell Beth's mother to take her tiny struggling child to Coney Island.
那时他已经不年轻了。78年前，贝丝的母亲被紧急送往她家附近的一家医院。她怀孕才六个月。她生下了一对痛苦地微小的双胞胎。一个在出生后不久就夭折了。贝丝只是一个婴儿的影子。体重仅一磅半多一点，她只有她应该体重的三分之一。医院工作人员别无选择，只能告诉贝丝的母亲把她那微小而挣扎的孩子带到康尼岛。
She was totally against it. When the doctor said that she had a send me, let me go to Dr. Coney, she was, no, I'm not. My baby is not a freak, she's not going to a side show. No way. And I took a personal visit from Dr. Kuhny to convince her to let him take me. By now Kuhny was in his 70s. He knew this child would not survive without his help.
她完全反对。当医生说她必须把我送去给库尼医生时，她拒绝了：“不，我不会。我的孩子不是怪物，她不会去杂耍表演。没门。”最后是库尼医生亲自登门拜访才说服她让我去。那时库尼已经70多岁了。他知道如果没有他的帮助，这个孩子活不下来。
He pleaded with Beth's mother. And finally, she agreed. Beth says it's the only reason she's alive today. The doctors didn't want it. They felt that the babies were weaklings, either they lived or they died, and nobody made any great effort to save them. Beth was an attraction. The nursing staff would take a wedding band and put it around her wrist just to show how tiny she was, as though it wasn't obvious. There wasn't any clothing that fit her,
他恳求贝丝的母亲。最终，她同意了。贝丝说这是她今天还活着的唯一原因。医生们不想要它。他们觉得这些婴儿是弱者，要么活要么死，没有人做出任何巨大的努力去拯救他们。贝丝是一个景点。护理人员会拿一枚结婚戒指套在她的手腕上，只是为了展示她有多小，尽管这并不明显。没有任何衣服适合她，
so she literally wore dolls clothes. But if you ask Beth, she considers herself lucky. Her parents visited her every day, and they grew to trust and respect the same showman who convinced them to turn their daughter into a side show attraction. My parents took me to visit him every fall this day until he passed away because that's how they felt about him. In 1943, a Brooklyn hospital opened the city's first department for premature infants and Martin Cuny closed up shop at Cuny
所以她实际上穿的是玩偶的衣服。但如果你问贝丝，她认为自己很幸运。她的父母每天都去看她，他们开始信任并尊重那个说服他们把女儿变成杂耍表演景点的表演者。我的父母每天都带我去看他，直到他去世，因为这就是他们对他的感觉。1943年，一家布鲁克林医院开设了该市第一个早产儿部门，马丁·库尼关闭了康尼岛的店面。
Island. He told his family, his work was finished. Cuny had blown all of his savings keeping his incubator shows operating in New York. He lived off checks from sympathetic donors like Julius Hesse, but seven years after his last show, Martin Cuny died penniless. Beth Allen's parents were out of his funeral. I'm so proud to be an incubator baby because they're so few of us now who are left to tell the story and make sure that Dr. Cooney gets all the praise he deserves. And what do you have to say to the people who think that this was exploitative or wrong. I say, look at me. Here I am.
他告诉家人，他的工作完成了。库尼花光了他所有的积蓄来维持他在纽约的保育箱展览。他靠朱利叶斯·赫斯等富有同情心的捐赠者的支票生活，但在最后一场展览七年后，马丁·库尼在贫困中去世。贝丝·艾伦的父母参加了他的葬礼。我为自己是一个保育箱婴儿感到非常自豪，因为现在剩下的能讲述这个故事并确保库尼医生得到他应得的所有赞誉的人已经很少了。你对那些认为这是剥削或错误的人有什么想说的吗？我说，看看我。我就在这里。
Beth is just one of the amusement park babies to come out of Cuny's 45-year tenure as the side-show doctor. Despite everything, Martin Cuny's attractions saved nearly 7,000 babies, kept alive for our amusement. Up next, more of the consequences of putting babies on display. The story of the Dion Quintuplets after this. So I'm now talking with Katie Thornton who reported that story. And the amazing part about the Dr. Cooney story is that even though you can feel kind of weird and queasy about the scenario by the end, especially when you hear from Beth, you know, this is a happy ending to this story. Like, he did a lot of good and saved a lot of baby's lives, but you came across another incubator story when you were researching this that did not end that well.
贝丝只是库尼作为杂耍表演医生45年任期内走出的游乐园婴儿之一。尽管有种种争议，马丁·库尼的景点拯救了近7000名婴儿，为了我们的娱乐而让他们活了下来。接下来，更多关于把婴儿当作展品的后果。在这之后，是迪翁五胞胎的故事。我现在正在和报道那个故事的凯蒂·桑顿交谈。关于库尼医生的故事，令人惊奇的部分是，即使你最终会对这个场景感到有点奇怪和恶心，特别是当你听到贝丝的讲述时，你知道，这是一个快乐的结局。他做了很多好事，拯救了很多婴儿的生命，但你在研究这个故事时遇到了另一个保育箱故事，结局并不那么好。
Yeah, totally. So, I mean, the whole thing is super conflicting, but definitely talking with Beth and talking with Don, they all met other babies of Dr. Kunis and they all kind of said the same thing that Beth said, which is just that they felt saved and they knew they wouldn't have survived otherwise. But I did come across a story from the 1930s and took place in rural Ontario's more than 200 miles north of Toronto,
是的，完全是。所以，我的意思是，整件事非常矛盾，但绝对是和贝丝以及唐交谈，他们都见过库尼医生的其他婴儿，他们都说了贝丝说的那种话，就是他们感到被拯救了，而且他们知道如果没有他，他们就不会存活下来。但我确实遇到了一个20世纪30年代的故事，发生在安大略省农村，距离多伦多以北200多英里，
outside of a town called Callender. And basically, in the 1930s, it was during the Depression, this guy contacted his local newspaper, and he's basically like, hey, is it more expensive for me to announce like five babies being born rather than just one? Because my sister-in-law just had five babies. Well, that's amazing that that was his concern. Right.
在一个叫卡伦德的小镇外。基本上，在20世纪30年代，那是大萧条时期，这个家伙联系了他的当地报纸，他基本上是说，嘿，我宣布生了五个婴儿比只生一个更贵吗？因为我的嫂子刚生了五个婴儿。好吧，他关心的是这个，这太令人惊讶了。对。
It's the cost of the announcement in the newspaper, but that's great. And then like classic small town paper, the person who's placing the birth announcements is like the ad guy, but he's also a staff reporter. So he's like, no way, you're full of it. And so he goes out there, the uncle is like, no, I swear, she had five babies.
这是报纸上公告的费用，但这很棒。然后像典型的小镇报纸一样，那个发布出生公告的人是广告员，但他也是一名专职记者。所以他说，不可能，你在吹牛。于是他去了那里，叔叔说，不，我发誓，她生了五个婴儿。
Because at the time, there was no quintuplets that were known to have survived. So the staff reporter goes out there, and he's like, yes, there's actually quintuplets, and then it just gets picked up all over the US and all over Canada. And so did they end up surviving? Yeah, all five of them survived.
因为当时，还没有已知的五胞胎存活下来的记录。所以那位专职记者去了那里，他说，是的，确实有五胞胎，然后这个消息就在美国和加拿大各地传开了。所以他们最终存活下来了吗？是的，他们五个都存活了下来。
And as you mentioned, it was because of an incubator. So basically, remember how we were talking about the Chicago World's Fair in 1933 and 1934, where they did the reunion. Right, right. So the quintuplets were born, they were called the Deons, and they were born two days after the fair started, and it was actually William Randolph Hearst, the newspaper magnate, who
正如你提到的，这是因为一个保育箱。所以基本上，还记得我们谈论1933年和1934年芝加哥世界博览会时，他们举办了重聚活动吗？对，对。所以五胞胎出生了，他们被称为“迪翁”，他们在博览会开始两天后出生，实际上是报业大亨威廉·伦道夫·赫斯特，他
was like, get Cooney up there, get him up to calendar, outside of calendar, really fun with an Ontario, and Cooney said no, but Hearst sent up a reporter, and with a reporter he sent them an incubator, because they knew that the babies would need an incubator to survive. They didn't have electricity in the house, so they sent up this gas-powered incubator. And I guess it was this whole fiasco at the border,
当时说，把库尼弄到那里去，把他弄到卡伦德，在卡伦德外面，在安大略省，库尼说不，但赫斯特派了一名记者，并随记者送去了一个保育箱，因为他们知道婴儿需要保育箱才能存活。他们家里没有电，所以他们送去了这个燃气驱动的保育箱。我想在边境发生了整场闹剧，
because they were like, we have no idea what that is. But basically, it wasn't Cuny, but some other people from that same world's fair from a different attraction on the midway, flew to Ontario, and they asked the father to bring the babies down so they could feature them in their attraction. And they gave him a really big check, which was super tempting because he already had five kids, and now he had five more, and it was the middle of the depression.
因为他们说，我们根本不知道那是什么。但基本上，那不是库尼，而是来自同一个世界博览会、来自游乐场中段不同景点的其他人，飞往安大略省，他们要求父亲把婴儿带下来，这样他们就可以在他们的景点中展示他们。他们给了他一张非常大的支票，这非常诱人，因为他已经有五个孩子了，现在又多了五个，而且正处于大萧条时期。
So did he take the money? He did take the money, which is kind of where the story takes a pretty dark turn. First, before I took the money, he went to the local priest, and the priest was like, yeah, you should take it, and then while you're at it, why don't you give some of that money to the church? Because the church is responsible for miracles, and this whole birth is a miracle, yadda yadda, all this stuff. And so then everybody is like furious that he took the money.
所以他拿了钱吗？他确实拿了钱，这就是故事走向相当黑暗的地方。首先，在他拿钱之前，他去了当地的牧师那里，牧师说，是的，你应该拿，然后顺便说一句，你为什么不把那笔钱捐给教会呢？因为教会对奇迹负责，而整个出生就是一个奇迹，等等，所有这些东西。所以每个人都因为他拿了钱而愤怒。
So I felt like the parents were exploiting the children that they shouldn't be raising them. And so within two days, the dad was like nevermind. He gave back the check, but everybody was already super angry. The public was outraged and they put a bunch of pressure on the Ontario government not to let the parents raise the kids. Oh, my.
所以我感觉父母在剥削他们不应该抚养的孩子。所以两天之内，父亲就说算了。他退还了支票，但每个人都已经非常生气了。公众感到愤怒，他们向安大略省政府施加了很大压力，不让父母抚养孩子。天哪。
So what did the Ontario government end up doing? They did end up getting a legal order to take the quintuplets away from their parents, and then they passed a Deon quintuplets Guardianship Act, which made the quintuplets wards of the crown. So basically removed all authority from the parents and made them the responsibility of the government.
那么安大略省政府最终做了什么？他们确实最终获得了法律命令，把五胞胎从父母身边带走，然后他们通过了《迪翁五胞胎监护法》，使五胞胎成为王室的受监护人。所以基本上剥夺了父母的所有权力，使他们成为政府的责任。
And then they realized, hey, there's a lot of interest in this. We can make a lot of money off of this. And they built this sort of like hospital slash nursery for them to grow up in. And it basically became a theme park. They called it Quintland and people would travel up to Northern Ontario
然后他们意识到，嘿，人们对此很有兴趣。我们可以从中赚很多钱。他们为她们建造了一个类似于医院兼托儿所的地方，让她们在里面长大。它基本上变成了一个主题公园。他们称之为“五胞胎乐园”，人们会前往安大略省北部
to go to Quintland. Oh my God, this is so grim. So did people end up coming to Quintland? Yeah, they totally came to Quintland. I mean, the Quintubletors supposedly taken to prevent their exploitation, but then they absolutely are exploited by this guardianship board. They were super, super popular.
去“五胞胎乐园”。天哪，这太阴森了。所以人们最终真的去了“五胞胎乐园”吗？是的，他们完全去了“五胞胎乐园”。我的意思是，五胞胎据说是为了防止她们被剥削而被带走的，但随后她们绝对被这个监护委员会剥削了。她们非常非常受欢迎。
They were in a bunch of American newsreels, so all these Americans knew about them. Actually, there's still some of those newsreels available, so maybe we can watch one together. Cool. Okay, I have one here. I'll get it started. Okay, so it says the Dion triplets at Calendar Ontario. Nowadays, selling Dion souvenirs is a thriving trade. But while they wait outside, we go in to find the two and a half year old little girls enjoying the final dip of the season in their own private bathing pool.
她们出现在许多美国新闻短片中，所以所有这些美国人都知道她们。实际上，仍然有一些新闻短片可用，所以也许我们可以一起看一个。酷。好的，我这里有一个。我开始播放。好的，上面写着“安大略省卡伦德的迪翁五胞胎”。如今，销售迪翁纪念品是一项繁荣的贸易。但当他们在外面等待时，我们进去发现两岁半的小女孩们正在她们自己的私人游泳池里享受这个季节的最后一次浸泡。
That's Yvonne, with the ribbon in her hair. She's generous. But then they're all generous. In the play yard, Y yard even takes the center of the state and already she's got that This is my husband right so Yeah, it's terrible because like you know how terrible their story is and yet it's just so cute Yeah, it's like a nightmare Like she's wearing a cowboy hat. Yeah, I can't handle it. And they're just surrounded by this little fence. It's a little zoo for babies.
那是伊冯，头发上系着丝带。她很慷慨。但她们都很慷慨。在游乐场里，伊冯甚至占据了舞台的中心，她已经有了那种……这是我的丈夫，对吧？所以……是的，这太可怕了，因为你知道她们的故事有多糟糕，但它又太可爱了。是的，这就像一场噩梦。她戴着牛仔帽。是的，我受不了了。她们只是被这个小栅栏包围着。这是一个婴儿小动物园。
Totally. Yeah, it was absolutely a zoo for babies. And that's really how people treated it. Like they came to Norganontario. They would watch the girls as they grew up for years and years of their childhood through like one way glass. But obviously the girls knew that they were there
完全是。是的，这绝对是一个婴儿动物园。这确实是人们对待它的方式。就像他们来到安大略省北部。他们会看着女孩们长大，看着她们童年的岁月，透过单向玻璃。但显然女孩们知道他们在那里，
because they could hear them. And it was just like pretty bleak. And in addition to the zoo aspect of just watching the girls who are adorable, walking around and interacting the way toddlers do. There was this huge gift shop, associated with a front, they're like souvenirs and stuff. I mean, this became such a market.
因为她们能听到他们的声音。这简直太凄凉了。除了观看那些可爱的女孩们走来走去、像蹒跚学步的孩子那样互动这种动物园式的方面之外。还有一个巨大的礼品店，与一个前台相关联，他们有纪念品之类的东西。我的意思是，这变成了一个市场。
There was such a cottage industry around it. Like they had these dolls and their dolls outsold Shirley Temple dolls, five to one. I think that's wild. I've heard of Shirley Temple, but I'd never heard of the thing on Quintuplets before this story. People would just take random rocks from the area and sell them as fertility rocks because people would go there because I thought there was something magical about the soil there.
围绕它形成了一个家庭手工业。他们有这些玩偶，她们的玩偶销量是秀兰·邓波儿玩偶的五倍。我觉得这太疯狂了。我听说过秀兰·邓波儿，但在故事之前我从未听说过迪翁五胞胎。人们会从该地区捡起随机的石头，把它们作为生育石出售，因为人们会去那里，因为他们认为那里的土壤有什么神奇之处。
Amelia Earhart came to visit, like just a few weeks before she went missing. And kind of in the same way that we started the story with that building in Minneapolis, you could really do the same thing with Quint Land because you could say like there's a six lane highway in the middle of nowhere in Northern Ontario because they built all this infrastructure to get all the tourists out there. And they were in all these ads. I mean, there was a lot of money made off these young girls. And I mean, that's a lot of pressure to put on a bunch of kids who probably don't know
阿梅莉亚·埃尔哈特在失踪前几周来参观过。就像我们以明尼阿波利斯的建筑开始这个故事一样，你真的可以用“五胞胎乐园”做同样的事情，因为你可以说，在安大略省北部的荒郊野外有一条六车道的高速公路，因为他们建造了所有这些基础设施来把所有的游客带到那里。她们出现在所有这些广告中。我的意思是，这些年轻女孩赚了很多钱。我的意思是，给一群可能不知道的孩子施加那么大的压力
any different, but how did they cope under that sort of pressure? It didn't end when they were children, of course. Like they never got to learn normal social skills. They never got to learn normal life skills. I don't remember exactly what the story was, but I think one of them when she was 18 and she was out on her own, like she had never handled cash before, so she didn't know how to spend money.
任何不同，但她们在那种压力下是如何应对的？当然，这并没有在她们还是孩子时结束。她们从来没有机会学习正常的社交技能。她们从来没有机会学习正常的生活技能。我不记得确切的故事是什么，但我认为其中一个在18岁时，她独自一人，她以前从未处理过现金，所以她不知道如何花钱。
And it's all really twisted because the Ontario government, like you said, they supposedly took over their guardianship to keep the quintuplets from being exploited, but instead the Ontario government did a lot of exploitation. They spent all this money that was supposed to go to a trust fund for the quintuplets. They spent it all on security for their amusement park and salaries for staff. And so, later on in their lives, they ended up having a lot of financial troubles. So what ended up happening with the quintuplets as they grew up?
这一切真的很扭曲，因为安大略省政府，就像你说的，他们据说是为了防止五胞胎被剥削而接管了她们的监护权，但相反，安大略省政府进行了大量的剥削。他们把所有本应进入五胞胎信托基金的钱都花掉了。他们把钱都花在了游乐园的安保和员工工资上。所以，在她们以后的生活中，她们最终遇到了很多经济困难。那么五胞胎长大后发生了什么？
Yeah. Eventually, they went back to their parents of a long, drawn out legal battle. So they were nine and a half years old when they went back to their parents, but their family life was just super painfully rocky. Like they never got to learn how to be a family. Their father was abusive, it was really, really painful. And when they turned 18, all the quintuplets left
是的。最终，他们在一场漫长而艰苦的法律诉讼后回到了父母身边。所以当他们回到父母身边时已经九岁半了，但他们的家庭生活极其痛苦。他们从未学会如何成为一个家庭。他们的父亲有虐待倾向，这真的非常非常痛苦。当他们年满18岁时，五胞胎全都离开了。
and they tried to just find a quiet life elsewhere. One, maybe even two of them went on to be a librarian, so much quieter life. And it was just really tough. And then in the 90s, the surviving quintuplets decided to come forward about their exploitation. And that's where this person named Carlo Toreini comes in. He's a friend of the Dion's now, but at the time he was working in PR and I'll just let him tell the story. A book editor who's a client calls me up and he says, Karlo, we need your help. We have a book. It's about the Dean quintuplets. I told the Dean quintuplets, I know that story very well.
他们试图在别处寻找平静的生活。其中一个，甚至可能是两个，后来成为了一名图书管理员，过着非常安静的生活。那段日子真的很艰难。到了90年代，幸存的五胞胎决定站出来揭露她们受到的剥削。这时，一个叫卡洛·托雷尼的人出现了。他现在是迪翁姐妹的朋友，但当时他在做公关工作，我还是让他自己讲这个故事吧。一位身为客户的图书编辑打电话给我说，卡洛，我们需要你的帮助。我们有一本书，是关于迪翁五胞胎的。我告诉那位编辑，我非常了解那个故事。
Our de sisters doing today. He told me, well, this is exactly where we're putting out a book. I said, what's going on? He says, well, the three surviving sisters are living in the same house with a leaking roof. And they wanted to put out a book in order to help to pay for the groceries and to fix the roof. And I said, I'll can just be. I was I wasbergasted. Well, it's tragic. Yeah, it's heavy. And Carlo, something just a little bit of background about Carlo when he was a kid and he started school, he didn't speak any English. And he goes to the library in the first English language book he ever pulled out from the library was about the Deonquin tuplets.
迪翁姐妹现在怎么样了？他告诉我，嗯，我们正准备出版一本书。我说，怎么回事？他说，三位幸存的姐妹住在一栋屋顶漏水的房子里。她们想出版一本书来帮助支付生活费并修理屋顶。我说，怎么会这样？我当时惊呆了。这真是个悲剧。是的，这很沉重。关于卡洛，他小时候刚上学时不会说英语。他去了图书馆，从图书馆借出的第一本英文书就是关于迪翁五胞胎的。
And so when he got to work on this project, he got super emotionally invested, not just in the book. He did a bunch of research, and he paid lawyers and forensic accountants out of his own pocket to prove that the sisters had been terribly exploited when they were young. And he ended up getting them a bunch of media attention. Like, this is back in the 90s and all of these senior citizens of Canada start writing to the Ontario government, and they say, hey, this is wrong. You should pay some reparations.
所以当他开始做这个项目时，他投入了极大的情感，不仅仅是在书上。他做了大量的研究，并自掏腰包聘请律师和法务会计师，证明姐妹们在年轻时受到了严重的剥削。他最终为她们争取到了大量的媒体关注。那是90年代，加拿大所有的老年公民开始写信给安大略省政府，他们说，嘿，这是不对的。你们应该支付一些赔偿金。
And after years of work, he finally got them a settlement, which was pretty awesome. It was about $3 million. Oh, that's so good. The story is horrible, but I'm glad there's a little bit of justice in the end. You know, like all credit to Carlo.
经过多年的努力，他终于为她们争取到了和解金，这真的很棒。大约有300万美元。哦，那太好了。这个故事很可怕，但我很高兴最终有了一点正义。你知道，这都要归功于卡洛。
I mean, what a saint. It's amazing. Totally. Yeah, he's a really good friend. And obviously, money can never undo what happened to them. But two of the sisters are still alive. They're super close friends. They don't really talk to the media. They still want to live a quiet life.
我的意思是，他真是个圣人。太不可思议了。完全同意。是的，他真的是个好朋友。显然，金钱永远无法弥补她们所经历的一切。但其中两位姐妹仍然健在。她们是非常亲密的朋友。她们不太愿意接受媒体采访。她们仍然想过安静的生活。
They have some friends. They got their house fixed up. It's a museum now. So those are, you know, somewhat positive outcomes. Well, they're amazing stories. Thank you so much for reporting them and working with us again on this. It's been fantastic. Well, thanks 99% invisible was produced this week by Katie Thornton and edited by Chris Baroube and Joe Rosenberg.
她们有一些朋友，房子也修好了。现在那里成了一个博物馆。所以这些都是一些相对积极的结果。嗯，这些都是了不起的故事。非常感谢你的报道并再次与我们合作。这太棒了。嗯，谢谢。本周的《99% Invisible》由凯蒂·桑顿制作，克里斯·巴鲁贝和乔·罗森伯格编辑。
Mixing Tech Production by Sriviusif, Music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is a senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Homm, Avery Trouffman, Vivian Le, Sofia Klatsker, Emmett Fitzgerald, and me Roman Mars. You can find more of Katie Thornton's work at itskateethornton.com. Special thanks to KFAI Community Radio in Minneapolis and Don Raffel, who wrote the book, The Strange Case of Dr. Cuny. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco
混音技术制作由斯里维乌西夫负责，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔创作。凯蒂·明格尔是高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队其他成员包括高级编辑德莱尼·霍姆、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼、薇薇安·勒、索菲亚·克拉茨克、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德，以及我，罗曼·马斯。你可以在 itskateethornton.com 找到更多凯蒂·桑顿的作品。特别感谢明尼阿波利斯的 KFAI 社区广播电台和唐·拉斐尔，他撰写了《库尼医生的奇异案件》一书。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目。
and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Support them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and read it too.
并在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的广播街制作。《99% Invisible》是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 支持他们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我 @RomanMars，关注节目 @99PIorg。我们也在 Instagram 和 Reddit 上。
But Katie collected some amazing pictures of amusement park incubator shows. You can see them at 99PI.org. Radio Topeia. From PRX. Radio Tepia from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
凯蒂收集了一些关于游乐园孵化器展览的精彩照片。你可以在 99PI.org 上看到它们。Radiotopia，来自 PRX。Radiotopia，来自 PRX。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。